reports coming in indicate one person is
dead and dozens of others are injured
this happened on diamond bar road on the
way to the grand canyon west
the bus is believed to have started here
in las vegas we do have david charns
joining us in the newsroom
with what we know at this hour david
we're working hard getting you the
latest information and this is what we
can tell you right now there were 48
people on board this bus on its way from
las vegas
to the grand canyon our newsroom just
getting this photo you see here you see
that bus
on its side in the middle of this road
you can see the emergency hatch if you
look closely there on the
bottom of your screen in the middle of
that bus it is open obviously as people
escape from this crash and of course you
see lots of first responders there
now this is where it happened on diamond
bar road that is
how you get to what's called grand
canyon west and if you're familiar with
this area that's the attraction where
you can actually
walk out on the skywalk and there's
glass on the bottom so you can see
all the way down several thousand feet
right now this is what we know about
who was on board this bus 48 people
including the driver we know at least
one person has died in this crash
two people taken to hospitals here in
the valley airlifted from the site there
in northern arizona at least seven other
people having significant injuries
and 33 people taken to kingman
medical center we understand that their
injuries
are not significant they are there just
to be checked out that's the latest
we heard from the sheriff's office there
again 48 people
in total here involved in this crash the
red cross in northern
arizona also working this emergency just
tweeting this out that they are aware of
this crash
and monitoring the situation we of
course are working the phones here
trying to get you the latest information
here you see the
map there again of where this crash was
you see the valley up on the upper left
side of your screen in that crash on the
way to grand canyon west we
do have a crew on the way and we'll keep
you posted throughout the evening
on the latest on this just terrible bus
crash on the way to the grand canyon for
now live in the newsroom i'm david
charns 8 news now